so we started this show twenty-five and
a half years ago 100% of the time since
I've been on the air I have recommended
to you and I have personally invested in
good growth stock mutual funds I've
recommended for 25 and a half years and
I have personally for longer than that
invested in four types a fourth in each
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international now there's
always been a lot of noise in the market
when I went first one on the air the
first thing that happened was there was
a big tech stock run up the tech bubble
of the late 90s and then of course there
was the big 2008 crash that really
wasn't a crash it was a significant dip
but it really wasn't a crash a crash is
when something can't recover this
recovered it dropped in half and has
more than recovered obviously and as
we're studying millionaires and we're
doing a millionaire survey right now if
you didn't know if you're a millionaire
go to Dave Ramsey comm and take our
survey we're trying to learn about you
and how you become a millionaire one of
the things we're discovering is that a
lot of the people with a 1 to 5 million
dollar net worth that are 50 to 70 years
old have done so in their 401k investing
in good growth stock mutual funds now
there's books out there and people out
there to say oh don't listen to that oh
you can't do that you need to just
invest in an index fund an index fund is
an S&P 500 fund the Standard & Poor 500
largest stocks on the stock market
largest companies on the stock market
the average of those is an index or a
index fund is a representation of those
500 companies and if you buy an index
fund you will get the rate of return
that the stock market gets whatever it
does you're going to get up or down
you're gonna it's gonna follow the
market that is the baseline for the
stock market and so why would you not
just do that because that out a lot of
mutual funds don't outperform that
matter of fact one author said 90% of
the mutual funds the growth stock mutual
funds do not outperform the S&P well
that's a lie it's not true now a lot of
funds do not outperform so I had one of
our LPS one of our smart Vista pros I'm
sorry and some of our team do some
research on the stock market
the total large cap funds that are in
existence today that were around 40
years ago there's 84 of them 34 of them
in the growth category how many of those
outperformed over 40 years the S&P 500
well 30 of 84 did 13 of the 34 in the
growth category did so less than a half
debt over 30 years
there's 179 large cap fund 70 of them
were growth of the 179 51 outperformed
the S&P 27 of the 70 were growth so
again about a third outperformed about
67 percent didn't about 33% dead roughly
over 20 years
446 of those 199 outperformed the S&P
now we're approaching 50% in the last 20
years that have outperformed and then
when you look at the last 10 years it's
247 out of 9:57 back down to about 25%
30% somewhere in there so somewhere
between the last 10 and 40 years general
average is somewhere around a third of
the mutual funds the growth stock mutual
funds have outperformed the SPF the two
thirds have not so that means if you
throw three darts at a dartboard
blindfolded two of them would hit funds
that underperformed and one would hit a
fund that performed
if you were just guessing but if you
were to look at the actual track record
of the mutual fund and see that for the
last 25 years it has outperformed the
S&P or for the last 30 years it's
outperformed the S&P it's a reasonable
man's assumption a reasonable woman's
assumption that that fun might be one of
the ones that continues to outperform
the S&P I own several such funds I pick
funds that have beat the S&P that have
done better than the stock market and so
how have mine done well over the last 40
years my four mutual funds have averaged
13.4% the S&P has averaged eleven point
eight percent
so I beat it ATS in the last 40 years
last thirty years my mix is averaged
11.3% the SP is averaged ten point eight
nine percent I beat it in the last 20
years I've averaged what she thinks
includes the dip the huge dip in 2008
averaged eight point five three percent
and the SP is averaged seven point one
two percent so the four mutual funds
that I have bought in the cavour
categories that have outperformed the
S&P have as a group outperform the SP on
a 40 a 30 and a 20 year track record on
ten year the same thing happens it's
very simple I own one mutual fund that
started in 1973 and has an average
annual return since 1973 of thirteen
point four three percent out of that
forty four years seven of those years it
was down 37 of those years it was up
another mutual fund that started in 1934
that has an average annual return since
1934 eighty-three years the average
annual return is twelve point O seven
percent then out of that eighty-three
years fifteen years have been down
sixty-eight years were up that's a
pretty stable investment he's good at
getting people out of that B doesn't
know anything at all about investing
well just don't run the portfolio that a
same portfolio of endorsed and
personally done for 25 years I beat the
SP every year with it and I'm not
jumping in and out I'm not picking
stocks or anything like that I just
picked mutual funds that had a track
record of outperforming the S&P it's
really not rocket science and they used
one of our smart investor pros to help
me do that
and I beat the SP every year and I've
made millions of dollars doing this for
my personal self so you can do whatever
you want to do with your theory and you
can follow your financial adviser who's
broke or you can do something that has a
proven track record it's up to you I
don't care you do whatever you want but
that's the actual numbers this is the
Dave Ramsey show